[Music]
that's exactly what i just said
oh is that grinder anyone we should meet
no
i'm getting married you are who's the
lucky lady i don't know yet what do you
mean i'm getting a range of marriage
what assisted marriage that's what we're
calling these days
what about love you grow to love the
person you're with
like stockholm syndrome
so your ideas for your next film i could
follow my childhood friend to marry a
stranger chosen by his parents
my big fat arranged wedding me the
parents
first
love contractually
huh
moe here both the matchmaker no photos
no no photos yet you're thinking with
your little you need to be thinking
okay
[Music]
what's your education bro he's a doctor
oh we're not just the top of the food
chain
and any vices i should know about
drinking smoking dogging
no dogs no pets no dogging means
something doing cats are okay
i've got news i got engaged hey what are
you like her
hi i
love it very skype
how do you feel about possibly moving to
london
she's fine with it it's a very
multicultural place
maybe you should focus on your own
choices you actively search out anyone
who is wrong no one can get close to you
am i just half the person when i'm not
with the man
is that what you think just like that
[Applause]
you know why the prophet said paradise
lies at the mother's feet there is no
love
greater than a mother's love for her
child we are happiness it's all that
matters
we all need other people there's no
weakness in
now the party starts
i used to think that i was scared of
being with the wrong person
but now i realize that i'm scared of
being with the right person
i've been very lucky to have them as
neighbours actually they've become like
family to me since your father left for
that teenage tour she's 35
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you